Gregorio: Hi.
I'm Joe Gregorio,
and I work in Developer
Relations at Google.
This talk is on REST
and, in the talk,
I presume you're familiar with
the Atom Publishing Protocol.
If you're not,
you can watch my other video
"An Introduction to
the Atom Publishing Protocol,"
and then come back
and watch this one.
So let's begin.
You may have heard
the term REST,
and a lot of protocols
these days
are advertising
themselves as REST.
REST comes
from Roy Fielding's thesis
and stands for
Representational State Transfer.
It's an architectural style.
Now, an architectural style
is an abstraction
as opposed
to a concrete thing.
For example, this Shaker house
is different from
the Shaker architectural style.
The architectural style
of Shaker
defines the attributes
or characteristics
you would see in a house
built in that style.
In the same way,
the REST architectural style
is a set of architectural
constraints
you would see in a protocol
built in that style.
HTTP is one such protocol.
And, for the remainder
of this talk,
we're just going
to talk about HTTP.
And I'll refer back
to the architectural constraints
of REST
as we work through
that example.
Now, it's simply not possible
to cover every aspect HTTP,
so at the end
of this presentation
there will be
a further reading list,
if you'd like to learn more.
So why should you care
about REST?
Well, it's the architecture
of the Web as it works today.
And if you're going to be
building applications
on the Web,
shouldn't you be working
with the architecture
instead of against it?
And, hopefully, as you see us
go through this video,
there will be
many opportunities
for increasing
the performance
and scalability
of your application,
and solve some traditionally
tricky problems
by working with HTTP
and taking full advantage
of its capabilities.
Let's get some
of the basics down,
some nomenclature
in the operation of HTTP.
At its simplest,
HTTP is a request
response protocol.
You browser makes a request
to the server,
the Web server
gives you a response.
The beauty of the Web is
that it appears very simple,
as if your browser is talking
directly to the server.
So, let's look in detail
at a specific request
and response.
Here is a GET request
to the URL
http://example.org/news
and here's what
the response looks like.
It's a 200 response
and what you're seeing here
are the headers
and a little bit
of the response body.
The request is to a resource
identified by a URI,
in this case like I said,
http://example.org/news.
Resources or addressability
is very important.
The request is to a resource
identified by a URI.
In this case,
http://example.org/news.
The URI is broken down
into two pieces.
The path goes
into the request line,
and you can see the host
shows up in the host header.
There is a method
and that's the action
to perform on the resource.
There are actually
several different methods
that can be used,
GET, PUT, DELETE, HEAD,
and POST among others,
and each of those methods
has particular characteristics
about them.
For example, GET is safe,
idempotent, and cacheable.
Cacheable means
the response can be cached
by an intermediary
along the way,
idempotent means the request
can be done multiple times,
and safe means
there are no side effects
from performing that action.
So PUT is also idempotent,
but not safe,
and not cacheable.
Same with DELETE,
it is idempotent.
HEAD is safe and idempotent.
POST has none
of those characteristics.
Also returned
in that response
was the representation
of that resource,
what lives at that URI.
The representation
is the body
and, in this case,
it was an HTML document.
HTML is a form
of hypertext,
which means it has links
to other resources.
Here is a traditional link
that you would click on
to go to another page,
but there's more
than one kind of link.
Here is a link
to a CSS document
that the browser will call
and include to style the page.
There's also
other kinds of links.
Here's one
to a JavaScript document
that will get pulled in.
This is a particularly important
kind of hypertext
or document
that's pulled in.
This is called Code on Demand,
the ability to load code
into the browser
and execute it
on the client.
The response headers
show control data,
such as this header
which controls how long
the response can be cached.
So now that we've looked
at simple HTTP request
and response,
let's go back and look
at some of the characteristics
that a RESTful protocol
is supposed to have.
Application state
and functionality
are directed into resources.
Those resources are
uniquely addressable
using a universal syntax
for use in hypermedia links.
All resources share
a uniform interface
for transferring the state
between the client
and the server
consisting of a constraint set
of well-defined operations,
a constraint set
of content types
optionally supporting
Code on Demand,
and a protocol
which is client-server,
stateless, layered,
and cacheable.
Now that we've
already talked about
many of these aspects
with HTTP,
we can see that
we already have resources
that are identified by URIs,
and those resources have
a uniform interface
understanding
a limited set of methods
such as GET, PUT, POST,
HEAD, and DELETE,
and that the representations
are self-identified,
a constraint set
of content types
that might not
only be hypertext,
but could also include
Code on Demand
such as the example
we saw with JavaScript.
And we've even seen that HTTP
is a client-server protocol.
To discuss the remainder
of the characteristics
of the protocol,
we need to look
at the underlying structure
of the Web.
We originally started out
with a simplified example
of how the Web appears
to a client.
Let's switch to using
the right names
for each of those pieces.
They're the user agent
and the origin server.
The reality is
that the connections
between these pieces could be
a lot more complicated.
There can be many intermediaries
between you and the server
you're connecting to.
By intermediaries,
we mean HTTP intermediaries,
which doesn't include devices
at lower levels
such as routers, modems,
and access points.
Those intermediaries are
the layered part
of the protocol,
and that layering allows
intermediaries to be added
at various points
in the request response path
without changing the interfaces
between components
where they can do things
to passing messages,
such as translation or improving
performance with caching.
Intermediaries include
proxies and gateways.
Proxies are chosen
by the client,
while gateways are chosen
by the origin server.
Despite the slide showing
only one proxy and one gateway,
realize there may be
several proxies and gateways
between your user agent
and origin server,
or there may
actually be none.
Finally, every actor
in the chain,
from the user agent
through the proxies
and the gateways
to the origin server,
may have a cache
associated with them.
If an intermediary
does caching
and a response indicates
that the response can be cached,
in this case for an hour,
then if a new request
for that resource
comes within an hour,
then the cached response
will be returned.
These caches finish out
the major characteristics
of our REST protocol.
Now, we said this architecture
had benefits.
What are some of those?
Let's first look at some
of the performance benefits,
which include efficiency,
scalability,
and user perceived
performance.
For efficiency,
all of those caches
help along the way.
Your request may not have
to reach all the way back
to the origin server
or, in the case
of a local user agent cache,
you may never even hit
the network at all.
Control data allows
the signaling of compression,
so a response can be GZIPPED
before being sent
to the user agents
that can handle them.
Scalability comes
from many areas.
The use of gateways allows you
to distribute traffic
among a large set
of origin servers
based on method,
URI, content type,
or any of the other headers
coming in from the request.
Caching helps
scalability also
as it reduces
the actual number of requests
that make it all the way
back to the origin server.
And statelessness allows
a request to be routed
through different
gateways and proxies,
thus avoiding
introducing bottlenecks
and allowing more intermediaries
to be added as needed.
Finally, User Perceived
Performance is increased
by having a reduced set
of known media types
that allows browsers to handle
known types much faster.
For example, partial rendering
of HTML documents
as they download.
Also, Code on Demand
allows computations
to be moved closer
to the client
or closer to the server,
depending on where the work
can be done fastest.
For example, having JavaScript
to do form validation
before a request is even made
to the origin server
is obviously faster
than round-tripping
the form values to the server
and having the server return
any validation errors.
Similarly, caching helps here
as it requests may not need
to go completely back
to the origin server.
Also, since GET
is idempotent and safe,
a user agent could pre-fetch
results before they're needed,
thus increasing
user perceived performance.
Lots of other benefits
we won't cover,
but these are outlined
in Roy's thesis.
But all these benefits
aren't free.
You actually have to structure
your application
or service
to take advantage of them.
If you do, then you will get
the benefits.
And if you don't,
you won't get them.
To see how structuring helps,
let's look at two protocols:
XML-RPC and
the Atom Publishing Protocol.
So this is what
an XML-RPC request looks like,
and here's
an example response.
All of the requests
in XML-RPC are posts.
So what do the intermediaries
see of this request response?
Is it safe?
No.
Is it idempotent?
Or is it cacheable?
No.
If they are, the intermediaries
would never know that.
All the requests go
to the same URI,
which means that if you're going
to distribute many such calls
among a group
of origin servers,
you would have to look
inside the body
for the method name.
This gives the least amount
of information to the Web,
and thus it doesn't get any help
from intermediaries
and doesn't scale
with off the shelf parts.
So let's take a look
at the Atom Publishing Protocol.
So for authoring to begin
in the Atom Publishing Protocol,
a client needs to discover
the capabilities and locations
of the available collections.
Service documents are designed
to support
this discovery service.
To retrieve a service document,
we send a GET to its URI.
GET is safe, idempotent,
cacheable, and zipable.
The response type
is self-identifying.
As you can see,
there's a content type header
of application
Atom Service plus XML
that self-identifies what
the content is specifically,
and the response itself
is hypertexted.
It contains URIs
for each of the collections.
That's what's highlighted,
in this slide here,
is the relative URI
for the collection.
Once we have
a collection URI,
we can post an entry
to create a new member,
and then GET, PUT, or DELETE
the members at their own URIs.
So here's an example of a GET
to a collection document.
Again, this is safe, idempotent,
cacheable, and zipable.
The response is also
self-identifying here
as you have
another content type,
application/atom+xml.
And again, the response
is hypertext.
Lastly,
the edit URI identifies
where the entry
can actually be modified.
That URI, you can do a GET to,
to retrieve it,
you can send a PUT
to update the resource,
or you can send a DELETE
to remove it
from the collection.
So as you can see,
the Atom Publishing Protocol
is designed with RESTful
characteristics in mind
and gets many advantages
from intermediaries
and the network itself
as those messages
transfer back and forth.
So, let's look at some
of the other idioms
that you can use in building
your RESTful protocol
to get some
of the advantages.
For example,
long-lived images.
If you have large images
that need to be transferred
back and forth
as part of your Web page,
what you should do is
set the cache for those images
to be very long.
If you need to update
those images,
upload a new image
to a new URI
and change the HTML to point
to that new URI.
Here's an example
where I have big-image.png.
And,
if we retrieve that image,
you'll see that
the cache control header
has been set
to a very long time.
In this case, 30 days.
If we made a mistake, or we'd
like to update that image,
what I need to do is upload
a new image, big-image-2,
set the cache control
for that to be very long,
and then update the HTML.
The idea here is
that you keep the HTML
with the short
cache lifetime,
and thus you
can update that easily.
So there you go,
a high level view of REST
and how it relates to HTTP.
Here's the list
of further reading
that I had promised you.
"RFC 2616" actually outlines
what HTTP is.
"RFC 3986" outlines
the URI standard.
You can read
Roy Fielding's thesis,
"Architectural Styles
and the Design
of Network-based
Software Architectures."
And there's also
this "Caching Tutorial"
by Mark Nottingham
which covers in detail
many of the things
we just talked about.
Thanks and have fun.